[Music]  to visit planet earth  you will have to be born as a human  child  at first you will have to learn to use  your new body  to move your arms and legs  you will learn to walk  and run  to use your hands  to make sounds  and form words  there will be so much for you to learn  and so much for you to feel  sadness  joy  disappointment  and wonder  [Music]  over the years you will try to make  sense of that happy  sad  full  always shifting life you're in  and when the time comes to return to  your star  it may be hard to say goodbye to that  strangely beautiful world  damn this book you're crying no i'm not  yes you are  you're definitely  saying you're crying  [Applause]  you